what's going on everybody and welcome to
tutorial series on tensor flow J yes yes
I did do recently a live stream with
tensor flow Tydeus we'll be covering the
exact same stuff only in the tutorial
videos things are much more condensed
and hopefully a little more polished so
the first thing to talk about is why
tensor flow jsy is a guy who mostly
programs Python interested in tensor
flow jsy might you be so tensor flow at
J s is like not really a competitor to
tensor flow in Python they're gonna work
together the the thing that tensor flow
taught jeaious is offering you is deep
learning in the browser for users with
no installs required right that's the
the power that tensor flow at J s is
bringing you now the problem is while it
is fairly quick it's not faster than
tensor flow Python and and I'm not
really I mean it could be foreseeable
that it could become just as fast but
it's unlikely I think but here are some
here's a quick speed chart basically
this is a single inference I honestly
forget what it is it's I think it's
object detection but it's not important
what is important is just comparing the
speed times of a single inference
between all of these things so this is
with tensor flow python on you know
running on cuda with a 1080 GTX GPU
inference time so like a single
prediction takes less than three
milliseconds on tensorflow dot j s on
the same computer it takes ten point
eight so somewhere between three to four
times faster if you're running it you
know natively not in your browser but
but this is still pretty darn fast
okay now tensorflow cpu is the delta is
even less where it's 56 milliseconds
versus 97 so not even twice you know
twice as fast if you ran it just on your
computer so for inference it's it's
really probably you know your users like
even in this case on a cpu that would
that's less than 100 milliseconds so
you'd still be you know let's say 10
frames a second of object detection I'm
not sure what else you would need a
really really high resolution or high
inference rate for but that's still
pretty darn good so and probably over
time it'll get
so this is done using WebGL which is not
the most efficient not the newest
technology and honestly doesn't have
nearly as much love as something like
CUDA does so I imagine that as time goes
on the wheel will see significant
improvements here so so so what's the
big idea with tents floette Jaso so in
my expectation with tensorflow jess is
the main use case is going to be just
transfer learning use cases so you could
you're because because of these Delta's
here in the training times like this is
on a single inference now imagine a
batch size of 64 multiplied over
millions of samples well that difference
is is gonna be very significant so so i
don't think we're going to be at least
as long as the differences are here I
don't think we'll be training large
models on tensorflow dot J's but there's
no reason to believe that the this time
difference won't shrink dramatically but
the the main thing to me is like the
transfer learning but also just in a
business sense this kind of opens doors
that we've really never seen before so
traditionally let's say you've got a
machine learning model that you really
want to use for you know and share with
people well you have to host it and
every inference that somebody wants to
make let's say you've got 10,000 users
and they're gonna make an inference
every second you need to have the
hosting capable of doing that so let's
say your Facebook and you're trying to
train models that predict posts that
users want to see or your Netflix and
you're trying to predict shows that
people should watch next
you have to host that entirely now in
order for you to do that you need data
from your users and you need a decent
access to that data from your users so
they have to share it with you now with
something like tensorflow @j s that's
simply not the case so all you need to
do now is host a 40 megabyte model or
maybe it's a huge model and maybe it's
500 megabytes either way that's all you
have to host you don't need the
processing power to actually run the
model you just need to share it with
people and then your clients they don't
have to share the data with you they
could share the data with you it could
be some sort of opt-in scenario but they
don't have to so they can have full
control their data yet still have a
custom trained model that that serves
them content or you know whatever it
does it completely cater to them but
they don't have to share any data with
you also there's all kinds of other
things like rather than serving ads
maybe you you have people you know
finding cures for cancer or just
detecting cancer early for people or
whatever right there are so many
different things that that this just
really brings in into the equations now
so anyways I think it's super cool let's
go ahead and get into it hopefully
someone will mark a time stamp for
everybody who doesn't care about all
that information I'm sure somebody will
post one by the way do you toriel starts
here okay so what do you need to know to
start so don't post the time stamp yet
what do you need to know to start you
should be familiar with with deep
learning so if you're not familiar with
deep learning and tensorflow I strongly
suggest you stop here and get somewhat
familiar at least understand there's a
million sources that can show you how a
neural network works but here's just a
super quick overview hand-drawn by yours
truly
you've got your input layers you've got
your output you want to map input to
output the way neural networks work
you've got your nodes right here these
little lines each line has a weight
associated with it here's your weight
like this is an input node input node
input node each one connects here has
some weights associated with it so these
weights multiply the value here there's
some sort of activation function either
it's beyond a threshold or it's lower
than a threshold basically gets a little
more complex than that but anyways the
idea is to over time optimize these
weights to make this input equal this
output there you go no one that works in
like 45 seconds and then other than that
you might want to become familiar with
with tensor flow but honestly it's not
really that required especially for this
series
so with tensor flow ajs there's kind of
there's like two major ways of making
use of tensor flow jeaious you've got
the core api and you've got the layers
api the layers api is kind of there to
act like Kerris whereas the core api is
there to act
tensorflow the coverage as of the last
time I looked it's about ninety ninety
percent with you know the things that
you can do in tensorflow on Python let's
say you can do 90 percent of those
things in tensorflow @j s so unless
you're like on the bleeding edge chances
are you could do it now so the other
thing to keep in mind is like I don't
know much JavaScript so there's a lot of
operations where I'm like HM how would I
do that in JavaScript and then I
remember oh I probably don't have to I
can actually do it with what I know and
tensor flow and use tensor flow
functions hit so it's actually saved me
quite a bit the one thing we could not
do I think I want to say it was random
or shot I think was shuffle I think we
were trying to do shuffle there's an
operation to shuffle or do random in
tensorflow
and I just it just doesn't exist
unfortunately the other thing to keep in
mind is tensorflow does a lot of the
same operations as numpy so so you can
even go that far so if you can figure
out how to do it numpy chances are you
can do it in tensorflow chances are you
can do in tons flow j/s okay now we're
getting started so you timestamp folks
someone could post the timestamp so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna start with
your typical HTML stuff let me figure
out where to put my microphone here okay
so in your typical HTML you've got your
head tags awesome you probably should
start with some HTML tags HTML and then
even though it's not Python we probably
should use the whitespace and be good
and then besides your head tags you're
gonna have some body tags so the stuff
in your head here is just gonna be the
things that we're gonna use
so like scripts we're gonna import now
let me go over to tensorflow J yes
tensorflow J yes so you can just do like
a Google search for tensorflow AJ yes
it's otherwise known as J s tensorflow
dot org will go to getting started and
this is what we're looking for so you
probably want to make sure you get the
latest version but take note I'm using
eleven point six or zero point eleven
point six so if something's not working
right or something's changed chances are
you just need a different version you
like use the version I'm using or you
can figure out what's changed and how to
overcome that but anyway let's paste in
our script tags so this is all you have
to do to start using tensorflow Tijs
super cool and now boom works with
everybody now the next thing I'm going
to do is we're actually gonna run this
in the browser so go ahead and save that
and then like right click this and then
open in google chrome so if you don't
know how to do that let me pull this
window you can just like right click
open with Google Chrome you can probably
use Firefox or your other favorite
browser but what we're going to do is we
just want to run a console so at least
in chrome that's f12 and then you come
over to console and then you get this
little console window here you see if I
can take the whole thing so we're gonna
kind of like code this live just to get
the idea for interacting with tensorflow
digest obviously this isn't how you're
gonna actually interact with tensorflow
at jeaious but this is just a good ID to
get familiar with how things work so
first of all to use tensorflow digest
first you're gonna define a model now in
our case we're going to be using I mean
you could use other operations and
tensorflow
is actually without defining a model and
necessarily but anyway constant model
and because I've already written this
before just I guess remembers what I've
written
but sequential so all we're doing is
we're saying this is a constant here in
JavaScript it's name is model and then
the model is just a TF sequential model
now you've got two choices
for models let me pull those up again
let's see if I can get there
I think it's an API reference proverb
probably model yeah you've got
sequential and then you've just got
model now sequential is your traditional
fee forward back prop you know just your
cookie cutter deep neural network okay
if you want to be able to do like
bi-directional or something like that
you're gonna have to go with TF dot
model and get a little more explicit
with things anyway so we're gonna go
with a TF dots sequential model now the
next thing we're gonna do is add in
layers so first I'll just do this
OTF not defined really not we should
definitely get away with that um maybe I
need to refresh the page I might not
have refreshed it let's try again can I
do this yeah okay so they don't that
happened because I did this saved but
this was already open at the time so I
just needed to refresh so the return is
just undefined it it's all happening out
you know often in abstract space so
you're not really gonna get anything
anything back here so the next thing we
want to do is once we have a model
defined we can just immediately start
adding layers so the first layer to any
model well that's gonna be your input
layer right so the first layer we're
gonna have is gonna be right here so
it's just whatever we're gonna feed in
and then you've got your hidden layers
however many you want and then the
output layer so in our case we're just
going to do a simple linear regression
here so we're gonna do model model dot
add and then we're gonna say TF dot
layers and in this case we'll do dot
dents and then you're gonna describe
that dense layer so how many units does
it have one so it's just going to be
linear regression so you're just gonna
take in one number and then you're gonna
do an output so let's in this case we're
just going to do 2x basically so the
input let's say is two we expect the
output to be four input for we expect
the output to be eight so units one and
then we're gonna we need to specify the
input flips input shape one that's the
other thing
most of the syntax in the naming or like
the names of things are the same you
just have to change the naming
convention so we're back to to camel
casing if you're in JavaScript now so
that's our input layer since we're doing
linear regression we really only need
and don't whenever you're actually
coding this in an actual you know
JavaScript in a in sublime or wherever
you're coding it
don't forget your semicolon anyway so
we've got our input layer now we really
just want to have a single a single
output layer so the next thing we're
going to do is
or actually Madol so we don't want a
we're gonna have a single hidden layer
because that's all we need for linear
regression
Wow would it why can't I type here there
we go so now let's do model and in fact
let me just take this model dot add
let's say units 64 the input shape will
still be 1 and yeah that's good enough
and then let's do model dot add and in
fact let me just do this again actually
boom units will make this it needs to
output to 1 because we're looking for a
single number out and then the input
shape is coming into it would be 64 in
this case so now what we're gonna do is
we need to specify some values basically
for that so we've got the model we know
we've told tensorflow hey it's a
feed-forward neural network but how are
we going to actually do the back
propagation in the the optimization
basically for the model so we're going
to say model dot compile and in compile
again you're gonna have basically a JSON
of elements now write it loss so how are
we going to calculate the loss in this
case we're gonna go with mean squared
error and then what optimizer are we
going to use we're going to use
stochastic gradient descent the other
thing that you'll pray if you're super
familiar with neural networks
so gonna pull up the tutorial here we go
obviously what we've got here is pretty
clear but then here the only thing we
don't really have yet defined as the
activation will probably will talk more
about activation in the next tutorial
right now we're just gonna use the
default I'm actually not sure what the
default is it might be rectified linear
I really don't know I'm not sure if the
docs are gonna tell us
let's try t f dot layers dot dents let's
see if we can just go to layers
monolayers basic dense activation I
don't know I'm not seeing anything
that's telling me what their default is
it's hmm all I know for sure it's a
linear activation but anyway we'll talk
more on that later
but it's just another parameter you'll
add into here but for the sake of
simplicity we'll continue on so at this
point once we've defined how we want to
compile now all we need to do is pass in
basically some data so we need some X's
and Y's so constants some X's and here
we'll do one two three four and five and
then we'll do constant wise equals two
four six eight eight ten so those are
your X's in your wise and then now we're
ready to actually train this model let
me make sure we don't end up going off
the screen here okay good so then we're
gonna save model dot train earned no
model that fit X is wise what did we do
wrong oh we need to darn I'm gonna have
to rename these again I'm pretty sure I
did the exact same thing I can't
remember for sure in the live stream so
so these are just you know your typical
JavaScript array which is unacceptable
you need to convert those to tensors so
what we should have done is constant X's
we're not we're just not gonna be able
to change this right now but that's okay
we should have said Const X's equals TF
tensor in this case it's a 2d tensor and
then done one two three four five okay
that's what we should have done but the
other thing we could also hopefully get
away with is just model that fit TF
tensor 2d X's TF tensor 2d
wise oh I guess we also need to assign
our shape if you didn't know I'm new at
this
so aside from so I think we could get
away I wonder I'm just wanted I just
wanted to play around here can we do
that yeah so interestingly enough if you
so common convention with deep learning
stuff at least in tensorflow is to be
super explicit as explicit as we
possibly could be there's a few reasons
why we do that one is for debugging
purposes two is for just trying to get
things to be as efficient as possible so
if it's it's no different than like how
do we speed up Python when we use
something like scythe on well we give
them types so so no longer does the
language need to figure out like what is
this thing that you're passing to me
right so so those are two reasons why
you generally want to be super explicit
so what we're doing and modeled that fit
is we're just passing a tensor right
we're not being explicit at all when
really so we did get away with this but
in general you'd probably want to go
tensor 2d X's and then in this case the
shape should be so it's how many so
shape you it's so easy to get confused
with this but it's like it's not width
by height it's like height by width by
depth I want to say but in terms of
samples just think of it it's always how
many samples do you have and then what
is the shape of those samples okay so in
this case it's five by one so then if
you did the same thing over here
wise what's the shape of the Y's well
should be five by one right and that's
why we want to be super explicit not
only do we want these tensors to be 2d
they should also be shape five by one
the other thing you could always say
here is you could just do length like
get the length I think it's like dot I
forget what the syntax is in JavaScript
but you can get length from similar to
how you get length in Python to make it
dynamic anyways hit enter okay so what
you get back here is this thing called a
promise what the heck is a promise a
promise is is
at least the way that I see it I could
be totally wrong I don't I'm not a
JavaScript programmer if you guys
couldn't figure that one out
but the way I see it's very similar to
just it's just asynchronous so so the
idea here is that you can keep doing
other things while a model is fitting so
while a model is fitting you could do
all kinds of stuff you could at least
not freeze the webpage right and but at
the same time before you use the model
you want to make sure the fitment is
actually done so a promise basically is
either unresolved I'm sure I want to say
there's like two three categories that
it could have but anyways it's either
gonna be resolved or you're gonna be
waiting for it I guess it could could
resolve error or be unresolved I'm not
really sure anyways some sort of
JavaScript expert could let us know
anyways we have fit the model now we're
ready to predict so model dot predicts
and then again we need to pass a TF dot
tensor to D into that prediction and
what are we going to predict let's try
to predict a six and again we need to
pass the shape it should be a one by one
and you'll see here what we get is
something that at least to me makes
absolutely no sense I don't see anything
here that tells me what I'm actually
looking for right and what's going on is
it's just like in tensorflow everything
is abstract it's it's you know we don't
have access to it right at least for me
this is all running on the GPU and it's
very inefficient to pass data to the GPU
and get it back so we only want to do
that when we absolutely need to so we've
got two options here one in the console
we could actually just say dot print and
that tells us the answer it's giving us
anyways is 1.74 not really what we were
looking for but anyway that's one way
that we could do it the way that you're
more likely to do it is with Data Sync
so do data sync and then there is your
answer that way so data sync is what's
going to get all that information about
whatever it is that you're referencing
here that's gonna bring it to the
forefront so that's not what we're
looking for right we're looking for a 12
and so first of all we don't really have
that much data but this is a perfectly
linear question so we should totally be
able to get the answer and and in fact
because it's perfectly linear I don't
really think that we have any concern
with over fitment so what should we do
well we should probably go for more
epochs or change the learning rate
significantly but probably just more
epochs or epochs so all we're going to
do is go back to model dot fit and then
at or not model let's see yeah model of
fit sorry and what we're gonna want to
do is you've got your X's your wise and
then we want to pass a third parameter
here and this can take quite a few other
things in it but for now we're just
gonna pass epochs so we're gonna say 150
another thing that this could take just
make sure I'm not off screen is
something like do we want to shuffle the
data which is pretty cool little feature
and so we could say true and in fact I
think that's a lowercase T for
JavaScript okay so we fit trained let's
make our prediction again okay so we're
getting a little closer to 12 awesome
the next thing we can do is rather than
train it let's try it for 1500 be parts
oops
darn it let me go back 1500 you pops
we're waiting we're waiting we're
waiting are we still waiting we're still
waiting for summers I thought it would
say promise unresolved but we actually
don't see anything here I guess we're
just simply waiting interesting
should be like 10 times why are we still
waiting there we go
wow that just took a while alright
anyway model predicts okay we're good
we're getting pretty darn close
eventually we should get almost there or
at least 11.9 and uh let's try like a
number that was nowhere near initial
okay so forty let's try two hundred okay
cool so okay so we've got a simple
linear model now obviously first of all
this isn't really where you're gonna be
doing your coding but I do find that
this is a good place to do a lot of your
debugging at least that's how I learned
tensorflow at JSA I would just code up
to the point where I knew the code that
I wanted to use and then I would pop
into the console and start adding things
and seeing how that would impact things
so yeah so I think using the consul's is
super useful and then obviously you've
got your little errors that you can see
in here too so chances are if you're
writing in here you're probably gonna
always have the console up too just to
see what errors you produce anyway a
long intro but there you have a super
basic introduction in any ways to
tensorflow jeaious now the next thing
that we're going to do is make a really
simple web application that uses
tensorflow Tijs to power it and then
we'll get into some more complex things
like like in this case we just you know
trained from scratch what about loading
in models what about training models in
Python transferring them to tensorflow
ajs what about like saving the models
and interacting with javascript and
getting that to work with your model and
all that and waiting for training so
anyways we got quite a few more things
to cover for sure but hopefully up to
this point everything is making sense if
you've got questions comments concerns
whatever feel free to leave them below
thank you to our recent sponsors if you
didn't know you can sponsor the YouTube
channel that beautiful blue button
underneath the video some people don't
have it depends what country you live
and I think but if you want to support
the channel you can do that you get a
little badge in the comment section and
then you'll also get access to videos
just like this
before everybody else want waiting for
monetization status and also you get to
vote on future content stuff like that
so anyways that's all for now I will see
you in the next video